- [Gary] What
episode is this 70?
- [DRock] 71.
- Episode 71,
late afternoon Chicago
now flying to Toronto.
You got your passport, DRock?
- [DRock] I do.
- Remember when you missed
that flight to Australia?
(light music)
- Yeah, just sitting in the back
of the car thinking about work
really but just broke out of it
for second and thinking about
DailyVee and this journey.
It's super interesting.
I hope some of continue to get
inspired and continue to vlog.
I really wish I did
this my whole life.
It'd be so fun to make,
you know, content
mash-up content
right now of like these days
like really in
the grind obviously
I assume that you
will show some of the
can't see moments of earlier today.
- [DRock] Only in
Chicago for a few more hours.
- Yeah, we only go to
Chicago for a few hours.
- [DRock] Is there a rule
that we can't stay for a day?
- I'm not giving you any
content right now, DRock.
I'm so livid.
I'm about to rip faces.
That was a nice
little bright spot
in what's been
difficult morning.
I'm super pissed at some
executives at VaynerMedia.
This is a fundamental low light
for me in the company's history.
I am, I have no idea how I'm
gonna build an organization that
can allow to happen what
just happened with (censored).
I'm not gonna, we're not
gonna air out the laundry here.
I will figure out exactly how
I got to this horse shit place
right now but the fact that I
have this completely set up and
take 10 hours to build a
relationship over the course of
two years with (censored)
and have it handed to us on a
platter and to have the
embarrassment that this is
is fucking asinine and is loser
shit at the highest levels.
Dropping the ball is
just not interesting.
- [Woman] We're ready.
- Ready? Great.
Interesting to see how I handle
things today versus those issues
back in Wine Library or in
that transition when I started
speaking compared to today.
Be really cool to
compare today's talk to
one from 2009 or
what have you.
If I was giving this talk four
years ago, I would've said the
following which is, and honestly
if you're making enough and you
like they way you're doing it
and you love your work life
balance like do you.
What's changed in my tone over
the last four years is knowing
what's coming.
And what's coming
is a bigger tidal wave
than the one we
just went through.
Really enjoying the journey.
Really appreciate the feedback
from the community and also
really giving a lot of
thought right now and being
introspective right now even
in the car, really trying to
challenge me and DRock.
Had some good creative
ideas I thought the other day.
(light music)
- [Man] How do you talk to
people about overcoming the
fears of getting out on social?
'Cause I think whether you're a
lawyer or not there's insecurity
that's (inaudible) there.
- I talk to them about their
first kiss, driving a car,
going to college,
getting married that's what is.
I don't know.
And those are all good things.
I think not adopting
technology is a bad thing.
Meaning you can go
out of business.
You can lose your clients.
They liked using you as a lawyer,
somebody started a
YouTube or a podcast show
that they like and they
go to them instead.
- [Man] Thanks for being here.
- Thank you brother,
thanks for having me.
- [Man] You bet.
- [Woman 2] Awesome.
- Awesome.
- Thanks man.
- Thanks for having me, man.
- Yeah, no,--
- I'm excited.
- I'm a huge fan by the way.
- Thank you, bro.
- One of our gentlemen who works
in our marketing department his
name is Ken Kelkatis.
- Ken?
- Yes.
Huge fan of you.
- You have your phone?
- I do.
- Let's make him something.
Ken, it's GaryVee.
I'm super sad you're not here.
He's not here, right?
- [Woman 2] He's
not here, I'm sorry.
- Ken, we will meet I promise.
It will happen.
Thank you so much for the
kind words and love brother.
I hope we get to
meet super soon.
Take care.
Alright.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- Oh my gosh,
he is going to absolute,
he's gonna be
like you set this up.
- You got it right?
- Yeah.
- Just want to make sure.
- You know what?
We can just sneak
across the front.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Woman 3] Hey!
- [Gary] Hi, how are you?
Good to see you.
Are you well?
- [Woman 3] Yeah!
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Man 2] Sup GaryVee?
- [Gary] Sup man?
How are you?
Good to see you.
You're well?
- Selfie?
- [Gary] Of course.
Thank you, man.
- [Man 2] Kick ass.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
Thanks for being here.
- [Man 2] Go Jets!
- [Gary] Yes.
- So when people
ask dumb questions--
- I love it.
- and I also use it as
a branding opportunity.
Whenever you do, just have fun.
- DRock, save this, let's put it
in the background of the show.
Of The #AskGaryVee Show.
(bell dings)
- And I'm glad I got
to talk to you because
I called my shot this morning
that I was going to do anything
I could to have a
conversation with you.
- Such a pleasure.
- If there's anything I can do
to be an asset to you,
I appreciate it.
- Thank you, brother.
- Thanks Gary.
- Your grandparents and
great-grandparents
didn't have this opportunity.
They couldn't do it.
The technology didn't exist.
They didn't have the luxury and
the opportunities we have and
for us to sit here and not take
it and not have a chance to get
the most out of it and to
take this huge opportunity for
granted because it's new
and it's hard work feels very
loser-like and I'm trying to
will one or two people per talk,
every day to stop doing it.
And so please, my friends,
understand how big
of a deal this is.
Get educated on it, put in the
work, 50 hours of reading and
listening will put you
at the top of your craft.
Another 50 hours of producing
and testing and getting over
yourself and not worrying and
just trying will put you in a
position for so much more
success than you
could even imagine.
I've become realistic that that
means only three or four of you
are actually gonna do this
but that seems great to me.
I'll take it and so I really,
really hope you understood the
essence of the talk and I really
appreciate you having me here.
Thank you so much.
(applause)
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks, man.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Are we doing Q&amp;A?
Does Q&amp;A happen here
or somewhere else?
Thank you so much.
However you take this
statement I can't control
but I will tell you this,
this is what it is.
Day in and day out.
Episode 71 is gonna look a
lot like episode 710
if we get there.
It's operations,
it's people management,
it's putting in the work.
The flights, the grind,
it's debating the future.
It's strategizing
the opportunity.
It's being practical
while on the offense.
It's keeping a million
different balls in the air.
It's juggling short-term
goals versus long-term.
Ambition.
It's just rinse and repeat.
And for people that are watching
this for entertainment value,
it'll be interesting to
see like what that
continuous unfiltered
reputation, repetition
of this grind
is gonna do for
your viewing pleasure.
Because one thing I promise I'm
not gonna pander or be concerned
about the fact that it
all looks the same forever.
'Cause that's the punchline.
Do you have the tenacity and the
ambition and the skills and the
hunger and the want and the need
to be able to keep doing it
day in and day out.
And day in and day out.
Through all the adversities
that trying to achieve something
special are
naturally structured in.
I'm interested in it.
(light music)
- [DRock] Are you, do you
think you're more refined?
- [Gary] I think I definitely
think to like, you know, it's
unbelievable and for all of you
at home right now, I thought
I was unstoppable and
great 10 years ago.
I'm just better now.
- [DRock] (inaudible)
- [Gary] Yeah.
I mean I'm just better
and I'll be better then.
Experience matters.
It's just part of the equation.
When you're 24
and you've got skills,
you don't want to think so.
You're different.
You know what it is?
It's like a baseball pitcher.
You throw harder when
you're young but you're a better
pitcher when you're older.
Toronto bound.
Canada, baby.
(light music)
- [Gary] And I think you get
craftier and smarter and even
know how to
allocate your time better.
And as great as I like to think
I am at focusing on the big things,
I'll get better at that.
I've gotten better at that.
But for me, you know, and
much like an athlete, you can be
craftier but then you
still gotta throw the ball.
You still got to put
the ball in the hoop.
You gotta still put the
puck past the goalie.
So I don't mind
getting my hands dirty.
I don't mind operating.
I'll never get too fancy
and sit in an Ivory Tower.
It's just not where I come from.
It's just not how I'm wired.
(light music)
- [Gary] And it's an advantage
in some ways and in other ways
I look at other people and I'm
envious they don't have a need
or a want or a desire to do
that grind-y, grimy shit
but that's just in me.
(light music)
- [Gary] And that
doesn't go anywhere.
No matter how much money,
fame, opportunity you get.
(light music)